in this video we'll take a closer look
at the evolution of Spider-Man's web
shooters from the 1970s TV show all the
way to the most recent MCU Spider-Man no
way home movie we'll also take a look at
some of the most wild versions of the
classic web shooters including hidden
wrist guns and even a zombie Spider-Man
that uses his veins and arteries as webs
stay tuned to the end for some even
crazier web slingers too but let's start
from the first live-action portrayal of
Spider-Man back in 1977 CBS aired The
Amazing Spider-Man a made-for-tv movie
that served as the pilot for a
short-lived TV series starring Nicholas
Hammond as the Iconic web Slinger in the
pilot there's a brief sequence that
shows Peter Parker creating his web
shooters however these web shooters
didn't quite resemble the sleek and
sophisticated devices we know today
instead they featured clunky metal
blocks for web cartridges an oversized
trigger and a nozzle that protruded
awkwardly to make matters worse the
actual web that shot out of the devices
in the series looked more like shoddy
fishnets than spider silk making them
pretty forgettable in Japan Spider-Man
received a unique adaptation that put a
fresh spin on the character and won over
many fans this version of Spider-man
bears more than a resemblance to the
American Mighty Morphin Power Rangers
with a similar style and tone while the
suit largely followed the design of the
comic character the web shooter took on
a bizarre and clunky appearance looking
like a collection of boxes mounted on a
leather bracelet but what set it apart
was its unusual capabilities which
included the ability to store the
Spider-Man suit and summon a massive
spider Mech known as the marveler San
marimi's Spider-Man trilogy starring
Toby Maguire as the iconic superhero
remains a fan favorite despite some of
the harsh criticism that it received one
of the most significant departures from
The Source material in the films was the
introduction of organic web shooters
instead of inventing mechanical web
shooters Peter Parker now had a natural
spinnerette on his wrist that allowed
him to generate his own webbing while
this take on the character was novel and
unique at the time it didn't accurately
reflect Peter's scientific abilities as
depicted in the comics while some fans
were excited to see the organic web
shooters in action others were
disappointed that this deviation from
The Source material left out one of the
most important aspects of Spider-Man's
character his intelligence and
inventiveness later live action
adaptations featuring mechanical web
shooters were more thankful to the
comics and captured the audience's
attention in a different way nonetheless
the organic web shooters remain an
intriguing and memorable aspect of the
Remy films in Mark Webb's adaptation of
Spider-Man Andrew Garfield's Peter
Parker took a unique approach to his
web-slinging abilities rather than
crafting the web shooters from scratch
Peter repurposed the chassis and gears
of a watch to create a distinctive
design these web shooters even featured
a small screen that displayed how much
web food he had remaining adding an
extra layer of functionality and
Technology to the devices The Amazing
Spider-Man 2 took things even further
upgrading the web shooters with Sleek
new designs and improved functionality
however these upgrades didn't quite
stand out as much as the earlier
prototype versions which boasted a more
unique and eye-catching design
nonetheless the web shooters in the web
vs Spider-Man films remain a noteworthy
addition to the hero's Arsenal
demonstrating the character's Ingenuity
and resourcefulness in creating his
crime-fighting gadgets Tom Holland
Spider-Man has been shown using a
variety of different web shooters
throughout his time in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe in Spider-Man
homecoming he started out using a pair
of homemade web shooters that he
designed and built himself these web
shooters were simple in design and
functionality using a wrist mounted
mechanism to shoot webs made from a
homemade web fluid recipe after helping
out in the events of Captain America
Civil War Tony Stark took notice of
Peter Parker's abilities and designed
him a new high-tech Spider-Man suit that
included web shooters with some Advanced
features these web shooters were more
powerful and efficient than Peter's
homemade ones and featured 576 web
shooter combinations including taser
webs web bombs and More in Avengers
Infinity War Peter Parker donned the
iron spider suit that was gifted him by
Tony Stark the web shooters on this suit
were even more advanced than his
previous ones featuring an even wider
array of web types and a more
streamlined design in Spider-Man no way
home Peter Parker finds himself in a
strange new world after a Bosch spell
from Doctor Strange while trying to help
villains from alternate realities get
back home Doctor Strange creates a new
set of web shooters that utilize
mystical energy instead of web fluid
these web shooters allow him to send
people to a group of cells underneath
the sanctum sanctorum adding a new level
of Versatility to his web slinging
abilities the Ultimate Spider-Man
animated series Drew its name from the
comic series but it only Loosely
followed the modernized continuity the
show's original original premise
depicted Spider-Man training with Shield
to become a better superhero along with
a team of young Heroes like Iron Fist
and white tiger this animated series put
its own spin on spidey's technology in
this case Nick Fury provided Spider-Man
with an advanced new web shooter that
boasted holographic projection and
invisibility capabilities while the
enhanced web shooter certainly added a
new layer of functionality to
Spider-Man's abilities it wasn't without
its flaws the clunky design of the web
shooter didn't quite match the sleekness
of Spider-Man's iconic suit and some
fans found it to be kind of an eyesore
while it may not have been the most
popular take on spidey's Tech it remains
a noteworthy addition to the character's
ever-evolving Gadget Arsenal the web
shooters and Marvel's Spider-Man game
developed by Insomniac were as
fashionable as they were functional
hidden within as civilian wristbands
until he needed them Peter Parker could
easily attach the shooters to his
wristbands when it was time to swing
into action the high-tech design of the
web shooters was fitting given that
Peter had been operating as Spider-Man
for eight years in the game and worked
as an assistant for Dr Otto Octavius
Insomniac went the extra mile to make
the web shooter Stand Out by introducing
several special webbing modifications
players can craft different types of
webbing from Electric webs that could
shock enemies to web grenades that
created explosive traps these special
webbing types made combat more Dynamic
allowing players to use different
strategies and tactics to defeat foes
insomniac's attention to detail and
creating a high-tech customizable web
shooter system added a fresh spin to the
Spider-Man Mythos in addition to Peter
Parker his clone Ben Reilly has also
taken on the mantle Spider-Man on two
separate occasions the first time he
donned the iconic red and blue suit he
made some significant changes including
creating a new suit design with a blue
hoodie and a larger spider emblem on the
chest however his take on the web
shooters failed to catch on with fans
Ben Riley's design for the web shooters
featured a band of capsules that allowed
him to fire New Impact webbing pellets
and paralytic Stingers interestingly he
chose to wear his modified web shooters
on the outside of his costume a design
choice that was unique to the Scarlet
Spider despite the mixed reception to
the web Shooter's design Ben Riley's
time is Spider-Man and Scarlet Spider
remains a beloved chapter in
Spider-Man's comic book history one of
the best and most unique web shooter
designs came from Earth 835 one which
first appeared in the comic series what
if the comic explored a reality where
Spider-Man worked with Wolverine after
accidentally killing Logan's friend
Charlie in their 1986 one shot
Spider-Man became a highly trained
assassin which influenced his web
shooter design the web shooters now
fired bullets instead of webbing making
them one of the deadliest versions we've
seen following the dramatic events of
the 2014 dying wish storyline Peter
Parker found himself trapped inside the
failing body of his arch nemesis Dr Otto
Octavius while docok assumed the role of
Spider-Man though initially delighted
with his Newfound power docok soon
realized that being Spider-Man was much
harder than it looked and that there was
much he could learn from his predecessor
determined to be a better Spider-Man
than Parker ever was docock set to work
improving on the original web fluid
formula creating a new and more potent
version that was not only stronger but
also bulletproof his web shooters also
underwent some upgrades with a built-in
camera and sonar sensors that allowed
him to better navigate in the dark he
even created his own spider bots to
patrol the city and gather intelligence
for a Time docok's superior Spider-Man
proved to be a popular hero on the
citizens of New York but it wasn't long
before his more brutal methods and lack
of compassion Drew criticism and concern
from his fellow Heroes eventually Peter
Parker was able to regain control of his
body and resume his duties as Spider-Man
but the legacy of Doc Ock stint as The
Superior Spider-Man would continue to be
felt in the years to come in the Marvel
Zombies Storyline Spider-Man gained a
unique ability that sets him apart from
his regular counterparts the ability to
use his veins and arteries as a
substitute for his webbing this allowed
him to swing from building to building
even though he was infected by the
zombie virus however unlike the regular
web shooters this method of web swinging
caused Spider-Man to feel pain despite
his Undead State Spider-Man retained his
sense of responsibility and continued to
fight alongside other zombified Heroes
to protect what was left of humanity
meet SunSpider the hero who wouldn't let
her physical disability hold her back
from fighting crime Charlotte Weber
suffered from a condition that weakened
her joints in connective tissue which
means that she had to use a wheelchair
and crutches for extra support however
instead of letting her disability stop
her from fighting crime Charlotte used
her crutches to her Advantage as sun
spider her crutches were outfitted with
web shooter that allowed her to swing
through the city and catch villains in
her webs with her quick thinking and
resourcefulness SunSpider proved that
anyone can be a hero no matter their
physical limitations on Earth 71928
Spider-Man went beyond just his usual
web-slinging abilities with his web
shooters he adapted his web-slinging
technology to include a small caliber
chain gun magazine his web shooters were
loaded with a variety of special
ammunition such as high armor piercing
electromagnetic pulse explosives and
incendiary rounds Spider-Man could
easily switch between ammo types thanks
to the sensors in his palms this version
of Spider-Man was a force to be reckoned
with capable of taking on even the most
formidable foes with his incredible web
shooting Arsenal in an alternate reality
known as earth9602 a fusion of Marvel
Comics and DC Comics characters called
the amalgam Universe Spider-Boy was
equipped with a unique weapon to Adam
and his crime-fighting Endeavors instead
of his trademark web shooters Spider-Boy
was given a special pistol that fired
synthetic strands of webbing this
technology allowed him to shoot webbing
without the need for wrist mounted
devices giving him greater mobility and
flexibility in combat situations with
this new tool in disposal Spider-Boy was
able to swing through the city and take
down villains with even more ease and
efficiency subscribe for more Marvel
content and if you liked the video check
out this one too